women mate across and up  success hierarchies and men mate across  and down the women like men who are  about four years older  cross-culturally they like men who  manifest signs of success as well as  being handsome and personable and all of  that and the reason for that as far as i  can tell is that they're looking to  equalize  the economic disparity that exists  because women take a harder hit from sex  and pregnancy than men so they're  looking to equalize that and no wonder  they're looking for someone who's this  is for long-term media who's competent  and generous competence would be  intelligence general cognitive ability  and the markers that go along with that  they want conscientiousness or openness  as well as other desirable personality  traits